- 500 videos, thousands of facts shared
and almost 10 million
subscribers, thank you for that,
all in the name of
battling misinformation.
And yet, I've let some pieces
of misinformation slip
off my tongue as well.
I'm human too, doctors make mistakes.
And here, I've compiled a list
of every time that I said
something medically inaccurate
on this channel.
Huge thanks to those who did point it out.
Peewoop!
(intense music)
I am not a fan of vaping.
I miss my hair.
It still has chemicals.
You're still inhaling chemicals.
Some of the flavors have
propylene glycol in them
which has been known
to cause a condition called popcorn lung.
That's my mistake.
I updated it in the
description of that video
but it's important to point out.
Propylene glycol is not the chemical
that causes popcorn lung,
it's actually diacetyl
that causes popcorn lung.
Small distinction, but
important distinction,
we wanna be accurate on the channel.
When I do these types of responding
to comments videos, I'm answering
from the top of my head the huge majority
of the time, unless you see
me look it up on screen.
Doctors do make mistakes
especially, mixing up chemical names.
That's on me.
They just dump a ton of
ingredients, active ingredients
into these things.
And people don't realize
that there's Tylenol
in some of them, acetaminophen.
In others like DayQuil,
there's caffeine in there.
All right, that's my mistake.
But I'm gonna say a 'but' here,
because there might not
be caffeine in DayQuil.
There's other stimulants in there
that are used as decongestants.
But there's also caffeine found
in other products, Midol Complete,
Bayer Back and Body, which
is aspirin and caffeine.
Excedrin for migraines has caffeine
in it because they theorize
in large blood vessels, cause the headache
and by shrinking the size of them
by giving you caffeine
which is an upper, they
can shrink the size of them
therefore reduce some of that pain.
So there's a lot of products out there
that do have caffeine.
DayQuil unfortunately, is not one of them
but it is stimulating, remember that.
Because a lot of the medications
that use decongestants,
also have an ability
to raise your blood pressure.
And I oftentimes have
to warn my patients who
have cardiac conditions
of that important point.
Big Pharma's first Adderall meeting,
"Meth but for children," it's so bad.
It's bad, but it's accurate.
One of the main active ingredients
in Adderall is methamphetamine.
My mistake, no
methamphetamine in Adderall.
There is amphetamine
and dextroamphetamine,
very similar compounds
but there is no methamphetamine.
There were a lot of comments about that.
And the reason why I sympathize
with those comments is because
people get unfairly judged
for using Adderall if
they actually need it.
And that's really unfair
because if you have a medical condition
and there's a treatment
out there that works
for you and people are judging you
because it is called meth
because it has methamphetamine in it
which is the same
compound, that's not fair.
The dosing is different.
Indications are different.
And remember, every substance that we take
into our bodies react differently
within each individual,
meaning that if you
have a medical condition
that warrant's taking small
doses of methamphetamine
and if someone judges you
for that, that's messed up.
If you can't sneeze, look
at a source of bright light.
If you can't sneeze,
do people walk around wanting to sneeze?
Yeah Mike, if someone is on the verge.
- It's like you're on the-
- Thank you Sam.
- [Sam] And you're trying
to ignite the sneeze.
- Yeah.
- You look at a bright light.
- And then, what happens?
- [Sam] It would make you sneeze.
- That's, what?
There's gotta be more to it.
Well, there is more to it
and thank God I looked it up.
The reality is there
exists something known
as the photic sneeze reflex where you look
at a bright light and
it causes you to sneeze.
A lot of times this is just a mild reflex,
but sometimes it can be quite serious.
There's actually theories as
to why this happens, not
even a well known mechanism.
They theorize that it's
cranial nerve five and 10
that are involved in creating this reflex.
It's cool that they have a mechanism,
but at the same time very weird
that it's only a proposed mechanism,
not even a well proven one.
- [Sam] Didn't you also
get egg on your face
in this 'cause you looked at light
and sneezed later in this face?
- Yeah, that's true!
Like, (sneezes), oh my God it worked!
- Try smelling this.
- Oh alcohol, gross.
- What the-
- Peewoop!
Is this?
Rubbing alcohol, still feel nauseous?
Actually no, thanks.
All of that is fake news, I'm sorry.
The alcohol inhalation
for nausea, actually has some evidence.
I looked it up, found
out it's actually true.
They used actually, non-pregnant patients
in an emergency room setting that had mild
to moderate nausea
and they had them sniff
alcohol one to two centimeters
below their nose.
And half an hour later, 50% improved.
And obviously, there
were different studies
with different outcomes,
But it seems like a really simple way
with low chance of adverse effects to try
and treat someone's nausea
without using medications.
Because the most commonly
used medication that we have
for nausea is called Ondansetron,
and it actually has serious
complications if it's used
in the wrong patient.
Meaning that if you already
have some cardiac arrhythmia,
it can make it become worse so much so,
that it could be fatal.
And again, that shouldn't scare you away
from taking that medication
if you're truly having
terrible nausea and vomiting.
It's just a known side effect.
Sniffing a little alcohol,
literally smelling it
one to two centimeters
of your nose, very low chance
of adverse side effects
in my opinion.
- I have a lot of upset
stomachs and a lot of 7UPs.
- Oh, this is our Grandma Bobbe video.
We have to say rest in peace to her.
She unfortunately, lost her
life after we filmed this video.
Not directly after, but
sometime had passed.
So, sending best wishes to her family
and making sure that they know
that she's in our thoughts.
First of all, 7Up contains caffeine.
Misinformation, Dr. Mike!
7Up does not contain caffeine.
I mixed this up with Mountain Dew,
7Up is actually caffeine-free.
Does not make it fine, by the way.
It's still not an ideal thing
to drink, nor does it
contain enough ginger
to actually warrant the
potential anti-nausea effects
that ginger has on our bodies.
(record screeching)
(crickets chirping)
What you're talking about
is, something I mention a lot.
It's called PTG.
PTG is post-traumatic growth.
It's a person who've gone
through something horrible,
some kind of trauma like war,
like cancer, family member who had cancer,
and they come out after
this traumatic episode
and they grow as a person.
They become better.
They find an outlet for their struggle.
- I've never heard that term.
- It's not in literature.
It's not something that you would find.
I came up with it in my own mind
but I've also now, saw
other people mention it.
I saw a reaction to this video
by a trained mental health professional
and they were critiqueful
of that statement of mine.
And I can under understand why.
What I was thinking to myself
in my head, as I was talking about it was
that post-traumatic growth was not
in the literature that was being taught
to me as a medical student, as a resident,
as a doctor, really.
Meaning that, a lot of the information
that we were being presented with
when it came to mental health was negative
meaning pathologic,
everything that can go wrong.
There was no research
articles being presented
to us about positive psychology,
like post-traumatic growth.
In fact, I wasn't even
aware that there was a term
in medical literature known
as post-traumatic growth.
It's something that I just kind of came to
in my own thinking.
Later, looking back at
it, there was plenty
of researchers who were doing
this and doing it quite well.
Started reading books on the subject,
learning more and more about it.
I did not create it.
I don't take credit for
post-traumatic growth.
It's very easy to say,
"Okay, here's what's wrong.
You have depression, you have anxiety.
And we need to fix that
and we need to get you back to zero,"
but what about helping that
person not just go from zero
but also into the positive state of mind?
Because a person shouldn't just be bland.
They shouldn't just
experience no emotions.
It should be a balanced
spectrum of negative emotions
that don't take them so far
that they can't control it.
And also, positive emotions
that don't take them
to a state of mania where they
can't control their spending,
their other urges and so on.
Did you know, putting
a, puttin', puttin'...
They didn't even get the G in there.
Puttin' a cabbage leaf on the breast,
take a frozen cabbage leaf and stuff it
into your bra over the
infection, what infection?
These things don't even specify.
That's a really good point.
What if the pregnant
patient has an HIV infection
and they think that the cabbage will help?
This will do wonders in treating mastitis.
Okay, now we've at least
localized the infection.
That's an infection of the nipple area.
This cold cabbage leaf does
the work of a cold compress
on the inflamed breast
and provides relief.
Here's the cabbage-relief thing,
'cause I looked it up, people
said there is some research
on proving that cabbage leaves do work.
And to my surprise,
there are some research articles on this.
I don't know who conducted that research
and some of them are of decent quality,
and they did show that
there was some relief
from discomfort, breast hardness,
breast tenderness, et cetera.
But I still think my point holds true
that if you put a warm
compress or a cold compress,
that it'll do very
similarly the same thing
without the risk of potentially adding
onto that infection.
Foods have bacterias on them, mold on them
and that mold can get into
a already infected area.
So to me, it's dicey to recommend this
as a treatment to patients,
and still largely
unnecessary despite the fact
that I will admit there is a few articles
out there supporting its use.
And if possible, aim for the organic sort
to reduce possible
pesticide contamination.
All right, well, that's
an important point here
because cucumbers are
part of this dirty group
of vegetables that really
need a lot of cleaning.
And if you're gonna be eating the peel,
you're gonna wanna wash
them very thoroughly.
And going organic,
this is kind of the mistake I made here,
does not mean pesticide-free.
It actually means that
they can use pesticides
but they have to come
from natural sources.
And as we've grown to know,
natural does not mean safe
or not toxic because nature out there,
is very much toxic.
Show a spider.
Oh, I remember this with the Pam video
about fake or real diseases.
We're gonna keep this covered here for you
because this triggered in a
lot of people, trypophobia
which isn't necessarily recognized
by the medical community
as a true specific phobia,
but it's the fear of small holes gathered
or clustered closely together.
And this image got people very nervous.
I had to change this
thumbnail very quickly
'cause the amount of comments
I got, we're staggering.
Please tell me
this is a neurosurgeon
doing this, not Foreman.
(chuckles), It's Foreman, oh my God!
They're all neurosurgeons,
infectious disease specialists,
family medicine doctors.
Okay, I can get offended here
and I still am allowed to,
because they act like they do everything.
They give no credit to nursing staff,
CMA staff, respiratory techs,
just so many individuals
in a hospital that work
to make it function.
And actually, patients have
probably more contact time
with those specialties and individuals
than they do even with the doctors.
But, a lot of you left comments saying
that, "Wow, Dr. Mike's
not a true House MD fan
because Foreman is
actually a neurosurgeon."
(clears throat), I looked
up the House MD Wiki,
didn't even know that existed,
and Foreman actually did his residency
in neurology so still not a neurosurgeon,
and then applied to be
a fellow under Dr. House
which I guess is like
an infectious disease
or diagnostician fellowship.
Still not a neurosurgery resident!
Still not a neurosurgery
fellow, none of the above.
He shouldn't be doing
this, it's unethical.
So while I will take the loss by saying
that he's not anything related
to neurology, he's still
not a neurosurgeon.
It's really unfortunate that
I have to knock out iDubbbz
after having so much respect for him.
But know that iDubbbz,
I'm only knocking you out
because of the tremendous
respect I have for you.
Oh, I messed up here.
Okay, I didn't knock out iDubbbz only
'cause I didn't know my man
has a chin of granite, steel.
I don't know, what's an
indestructible substance?
Whatever kryptonite he has, I
didn't have it in my knuckles
and I need to get back to training.
But I will say, I definitely hit harder
than butterfly kisses, come on iDubbbz.
- Sorry Dr. Mike, you
don't have knockout power.
Your punches are like
little butterfly kisses.
- [Commentator] Ooh, that right!
His hands right now, big right hand!
Throwing that right hand!
That again, overhand.
How is iDubbbz on stable legs
after taking some of these shots?
(butterfly smooching)
- And huge congrats to iDubbbz and Anisa
and Creator Clash
for raising $1.3 million for charity.
Woo!
Obviously, I come down
hard on natural remedies.
But here is a list of natural
remedies that actually work.
Click here to check that out
and as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)